Every chapter begins with these letters.
We have mention of the Quran right after
except for two chapters,
two of them. Number one, surah noon
and number two.
But there's a big reason why those two
chapters specifically don't mention the
Quran directly.
So listen to these verses.
Allah says
that
the Romans have been defeated but they
will come back from that defeat and
later defeat after. Okay. So this is a
prophecy. This is telling us something
that will happen in the future. Allah
says
here is anywhere from 3 to 9 in the
Arabic language. And seven years later
they came back and at by the time nine
years had elapsed they pushed the
successfully the Persians out of the
area of Am.
So this is a prophecy. This prophecy
is
something that eludes to the miraculous
nature of the Quran. So it's befitting.
So what about Allah doesn't mention the
Quran right after.
But he mentions
I swear by the pen and
all that they use to write with it.
What is the most
virtuous thing in this creation and all
of this create all of it from the very
beginning of the creation of the heavens
and the earth the jin the human being
the angels and everything that is
connected to this creation paradise
hellfire the dunya all of this what is
the most grandiose
thing that has ever been put to paper.
Huh?
What has What is the greatest thing that
has ever been penned or what has ever
been written?
Huh?
The Quran.
The Quran is the most virtuous words
ever used, ever put by pen to paper.
So when Allah says,
what is the first thing that is that
falls into what they use the pen to
write the Quran. And so it alludes to
the Quran but it is more broad than
that. Do you understand the concept? So
we say noon I swear by the pen and all
that they use the pen to write.
Right? What is the greatest thing that
all human beings, jin and angels have
ever written? The Quran. But this also
includes everything else. The deeds that
are written by the angel on the right
and the left, the future and that is
written for the
for the fetus in the mother's womb.
It is written. Allah sends the angel to
write four things. Right? What was
written in the preserved tablet.
Everything that is written, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
swears by the pen and what they write.
They here means anyone who writes.
Right?
Now, what is the point of this oath?
When a person takes an oath, when a
person says I swear by such and such,
there has to be something that you are
swearing for. Right?
We refer to this as
[Silence]
What is the what is the point of this
swear? What is he swearing by? If I say
to you right now, I swear by Allah, and
I stop right there, are you still
expecting me to say something?
What are you expecting?
[Arabic recitation]
I swear by Allah, I have three things
that this sentence needs to make sense
to be coherent.
Number one, what I'm swearing by. I'm
swearing by Allah. Number two, the act
of swearing. Okay, I swear. Number
three, what I'm swearing about. Right?
What am I swearing about here in this
chapter? What is Allah swearing about
here?
No.
He says in the following verse
he's speaking to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and he says you by the by the
grace of your lord are not insane are
not crazy are not mad.
So Allah is saying,"I swear by the pen
and all that it is used to write that
you, oh Muhammad, are not crazy. You are
not insane. You are not a madman." And
that is by the grace of your Lord, by
the favor of your Lord, by the
of your Lord.
Now this here is a response, isn't it?
It's a response meaning they the
antagonists of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam they are antagonizing
him and saying you're crazy he's cra
he's insane
right and so Allah is defending him and
he's reassuring the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and he's saying I swear
by the pen and all that is written by
the pen
that you by the grace of your Lord are
not in any way crazy.
You have no madness. You are not insane.
This is a revelation from Allah. Don't
allow them to get you down with these
accusations.
This has to come as a response
because
Allah is praising the prophet here,
right? But merely negating something
doesn't praise someone.
Do you understand what that means? Let
me explain.
What if I said if you ask me about
someone, someone comes to ask for your
daughter's hand in marriage and you say,
"She Ali, what do you think about this
guy here?" I say, "Well,
he's not crazy.
He's not a thief.
Well, he's not a liar." What do you
understand from that?
Tell me what you understood from. Tell
me.
some other trade.
[Arabic recitation]
to him based only on that?
he's not a thief.
What are you expecting?
Expecting there's something else there,
aren't you? Based only on that, you
wouldn't proceed with the marriage now,
would you? you'd feel there's
something else that I'm leaving out. Why
is that? If I said, "Well, he's not
stupid. He's not crazy. He's not a
thief. He's not a criminal. That doesn't
mean he's a good guy either. Doesn't
mean he's very smart either." I said,
"Well, he's not he's not an idiot."
Well, that doesn't mean he's he's very
intelligent.
Because mere negating something
does not is not praise.
Right? If you can imagine
praise is positive and dispraise is
negative in numbers. Okay? In numbers.
If I say someone is not,
you know, whatever it is, not a thief,
not crazy, not a liar, that brings him
back to zero. That doesn't necessarily
mean that he is what? That he is the
opposite of that trait.
So as a matter of principle, listen to
this. As a matter of principle,
every negation
in the Quran
that is meant to praise
holds with it an insinuation of its
opposite.
Those are fancy words, right?
It's very easy to understand.
Every negation in the Quran that is
meant to praise
insinuates
its opposite.
Okay? So here Allah is praising the
prophet. He's saying you're not crazy.
You're not insane.
This insinuates
that Allah is saying you are of complete
and high intellect.
It has to carry that meaning with it.
Otherwise, it is incomplete. It can't be
considered praise. The same thing goes
for the Quran. For instance,
this book, the Quran, it has no doubt in
it. What do we understand that verse to
mean?
It has no doubt. And we affirm what?
What do we affirm?
[Arabic recitation]
So we say the meaning of the statement
of Allah
[Silence]
for
So every time we see Allah negates a
trait and he's meaning to praise, we
affirm its exact opposite. So for
instance, Allah says
that the angels they never disobey Allah
in anything that he commands them. What
do we what is that affirming?
What's the opposite of that?
The verse means
that they never disobey Allah and they
always obey Allah.
That book, the Quran, has no doubt in it
and it contains all certainty of
knowledge and guidance.
You are not by the grace of your Lord
insane. Rather, you are of complete
intellect,
of full and utter intellect. You are the
pinnacle of human intellect.
Now, is it appropriate to call the
prophet or any prophet or messenger a
genius?
What do you think of that? Would you
to be called a genius?
What is the most
hurtful insult to the human being any
human being?
Huh? What did he say?
write an insult to his intellect
that will trigger every human being
because as a human our pride is our what
our intellect our mind and so any human
being old or young male or female
anywhere in the world
the thing that will insult them the
deepest
is an insult to their intellect.
If you speak down to them, if you make
them feel they are less
intelligent, any human being, that is
the number one trigger for the human
being.
Now,
that means we would all love to be
called geniuses. I mean, shucks, I'd
love to be called a genius. If people
referred to me as a genius,
, you know, seriously, not in a
mocking way, I would take great pride in
that, of course.
But that kind of
that kind of praise
is fitting for all humans except for
prophets and messengers.
Isn't that interesting? That is
an inappropriate description of a
prophet and messenger. And the scholars
have agreed that it is not permissible
to refer to any prophet and especially
our prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam as a genius.
It's not okay. It's not permissible. It
is haram to refer to the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
as a genius. Why is that?
What's the implication?
that the Quran comes from him,
that revelation is of his doing.
That's the implication it carries. And
that implication is not appropriate for
a prophet or messenger.
It would be appropriate for every other
human being if you were to take a
scholar's book and say, "Man, this guy
is a genius." What is the implication?
He wrote this book and it exhibits his
genius.
That is not appropriate for prophets and
messengers. And we'll add another one.
What is the Arabic word for genius?
They refer to a genius as someone who
is,
you know, this at the end of that word.
[Silence]
So what is
The word in the Arabic language
means this person comes from the valley
of Abar. It was a place right referred
to as the valley of Abkar. And is a
place that in Arabic lore, ancient
Arabic lore, they used to say is a
valley filled
with jin and shalt. If you go to that
valley, you will become possessed.
And so when someone would speak with
genius with an otherworldly
intellect
they would say he is
he is from the valley of why because
this is beyond human intellect. It's
a shan possessed him and spoke on
his tongue.
And even the word genius
comes from ancient Greek and it refers
to a guardian angel that gives the
person insight
kind of the shaitan gives from
these words are absolutely inappropriate
for prophets and messengers.
Now those connotations are fine for any
other person but for a prophet a
messenger.
And so Allah says
but then he didn't say explicitly
rather you are a genius. That's the
opposite of insanity, right? He didn't
say that. He insinuated high intellect.
Why? Because if he spoke of his high
intellect, it would carry the
connotations that the Quran comes from
him.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala didn't
mention that. But what did he mention
before? What is the symbol of knowledge?
What is the icon of knowledge?
Huh? The pen. That is the icon of
knowledge and intellect.
The icon of knowledge and intellect is
the pen.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
is being praised by Allah in the highest
regard while taking care not to bring on
implications that are undesirable for
his position. So Allah is saying noon
I swear by the pen and all that they
have written
you by the grace of your Lord are not in
any way insane or mad.
He then says subhanah.
He says, "And indeed I swear by the p I
further swear by the pen and all that
they write that you, oh Muhammad, have
waiting for you an unending
reward."
Why is he mentioning that after that
verse?
Because he feels bad. People are saying
these things about him, right? And Allah
told him to be patient.
You have to be patient. How do I find
that patience? How do I pull it out of
myself?
I remember the reward of Allah.
If you keep in your mind's eye the
reward of Allah when you are being
patient, you can outweight anything and
anyone on this earth.
And so Allah reminds him, be patient.
They're saying these things about you
that you're crazy. By the grace of your
Lord, you are not crazy. You are the
furthest thing from insane.
But remember, for you is an unending
[Arabic recitation]